oh boo - oh boo - I would like to begin
my time with you today by sharing a
personal story last year Starbucks
Coffee Company opened our first store in
South Africa and Johannesburg I had I
had never been to South Africa before
did not know what to expect
certainly could not be prepared for the
level of poverty and what I saw in the
townships throughout the city we opened
two stores and lines were out the door
in anticipation of Starbucks coming to
the market but before we opened the
stores I gathered the 50 young people
who would grace the green apron and put
on the Starbucks apron and represent the
company i sat with them for a few hours
and wanted to hear each one of their
personal stories and as they were
sharing their stories with me despite
their poverty their plight in life there
was so much joy and gratitude in your
hearts but what I learned was two things
one all 50 of these young people had
never had a job before they were all
unemployed for their entire life and you
should see the self esteem and the sense
of security as they were getting ready
for their first job but the second
lesson was as they were going around the
room and talking to me about their story
I kept hearing an African word I had
never heard before a word that Nelson
Mandela used all the time the word is
oom boo - UB u NT u oom boo - and
finally I got up the courage and I asked
what does this word mean that you keep
using and they couldn't wait to share it
with me and in unison
they said Howard butoh means I am
because of you I am because of you as I
have the honor to speak with you today I
ask you to keep that story in mind
because everything I'm going to share
with you today is through the lens of
Embu - I grew up in Brooklyn New York
and public housing the projects as it
was called back then my parents were
both high school dropouts and they could
barely afford $96 a month rent in our
two-bedroom apartment from my brother
and my sister and my parents however for
my earliest of memories my mother
instilled in me her belief in the
American Dream and the promise of
America that a good education and hard
work will open the doors to a better
life and that provides me with an
important lesson to share with you all
today that your station in life does not
define you and the promise of America
that is for all of us when I was seven
years old I had a defining moment in my
life I came home from school one day and
saw my father laid on a couch with a
cast from his hip to his ankle he had a
series of terrible blue collar jobs as a
high school dropout army vet but this
particular job he had in 1960 was
probably the worst he was a truck driver
delivering and picking up cloth diapers
before the invention of pampers he fell
on a sheet of ice in March of 1960 and
in March of 1960 if you were a
blue-collar uneducated worker you were
dismissed if you had an accident
no workmen's compensation no severance
and no health insurance and I saw the
fracturing of the American dream and I
saw my pair
parents go through hopelessness and
despair at the age of seven and those
scars though that shame that is with me
even today as a young boy I could have
never imagined that I would one day
build a company of my own let alone a
company that would have more than 26,000
stores in 75 countries and employ more
than 300,000 people thank you
but from from day one I really wanted to
build the kind of company my father
never got a chance to work for a company
that honors and respects the dignity of
work and the dignity of all men and all
women and that is why we became the
first company in all of America to
provide comprehensive health insurance
30 years ahead of the affordable care
act as well as ownership in the form of
stock options for all of our employees
including part-time people because it is
my firm belief that success in business
and in life is best when it's shared
Starbucks Coffee Company went public in
1992 and from 1992 to 2006 we were on a
magical carpet ride in which everything
we did turned to gold but in 2007 the
music stopped we had lost sight of our
shared purpose and our guiding
principles in which growth and success
began to cover up mistakes any disease
set in to Starbucks that disease hubris
we lost our way and believe it or not we
almost lost the entire company during
this cataclysmic period I was reminded
what it means to love something and the
responsibility that goes with it as well
as an understanding that leadership and
moral courage is not a passive act my
partners and I took it personally and we
transformed the entire company we
galvanize the entire organization around
our core values and servant leadership
every business every organization even
every family must be true to its values
and reason for being
our core purpose and reason for being
then and now has always been to achieve
the fragile balance between profit and
humanity today the equity of the
Starbucks brand has never been stronger
and our track record of creating
shareholder value and social impact over
the last 25 years has virtually been
unparalleled we have built one of the
most respected and recognized brands in
the world with the view that today the
rules of engagement for business and
business leaders have changed that we
must do more for our people and the
communities we serve and most
importantly that not every business
decision is an economic one and that
success is not an entitlement it has to
be earned and earned every day through
the lens of humility only in America can
a poor kid from public housing have the
privilege and the honor to be the
commencement speaker at the largest and
most innovative University in the
country
I stand before you as living proof of
the American dream joining many of your
parents your professors and generations
of graduates before you but today you
may question the strength of that dream
and the promise of America that's there
my generation has not made it easy for
you
our political leaders on both sides of
the aisle have not acted with enough
courage nor honesty in addressing the
long-term challenges we face
they have been more focused on fighting
with each other than walking in the
shoes of the American people
and vitriol and self-interest rule the
day in Washington despite all that when
I look to the future
I am extremely optimistic especially
when I look out and see you because the
future is not up to them not up to
Washington it's up to you this milestone
in your life may come with some anxiety
about what tomorrow holds and you may
have questions that only time can answer
but as a young man who once sat
nervously at his own commencement I
encourage you to always trust yourself
and to be mindful of these three
enduring questions how will you respect
your parents and honor your family how
will you share your success and serve
others with dignity and how will you
lead with humility and demonstrate moral
courage you are leaving this campus as
the best prepared generation in the
history of our country
[Music]
[Applause]
you'll each possess entrepreneurial
spirit the passion and the commitment to
create the future you deserve however
don't stop there
try not to rely only on what you have
learned in the classroom summon your
compassion your curiosity your empathy
towards others and your commitment to
service give more than you receive and I
promise you it will come back to you in
ways you can't possibly imagine each of
you is here today because of someone
else a parent a sibling a teacher a
neighbor a mentor someone who had faith
and confidence in you like my mother had
in me and nurtured your dreams as you
leave here today take a moment to think
of those who have come before you who
have helped you along the way who are at
your side today if they are here embrace
them and thank them for the gift of
Education and with the support and the
love that they have given you your
generation can bring people together
like no other
you can innovate create and lead your
generation will transform our economy
and create millions of new jobs you will
develop cleaner energy you will make it
so racism only exists in history books
yes you will you will be the generation
that teaches the world that we are at
our best when we recognize respect and
celebrate our diversity you can and you
will make your mark on our country and
our shared humanity dream big and then
dream bigger a more innovative dream a
more inclusive dream all of you will
preserve and enhance the promise of
America the promise that propelled me
out of public housing the promise that
will propel you forward regardless of
the color of your skin your religion
your gender your sexual orientation or
your station in life
[Applause]
please remember that ASU is because of
you you are because of ASU we are
because of each other
oom boo - oh boo - oh boo - yes say it
with me oh boo - oh boo - oh boo - oh
boo - boo boo - go forward and continue
to make your parents and your family
proud
god bless you and thank you and
congratulations to the class of 2017
thank you boo - thank you if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you Apple
so it would be collect a little beacon
hey believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details